JESSE WATTERS, DANA PERINO AND
MESSAGES FROM THE ANTI-TRUMP
LOVERS AT THE FBI.
AGENTS WHO WERE INVESTIGATING
HIS CAMPAIGNS POSSIBLE TIES TO
RUSSIA.
ON ELECTION DAY, LISA PAGE
WRITES "OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS TERRIFYING."
PETER STRZOK REPLIES "OH, MY
GOD.
I AM SO DEPRESSED."
LATER, I HAVE "ALL THE
PRESIDENTS MEN."
FIGURE I NEED TO BRUSH UP ON
WATERGATE.
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA KNEW ABOUT THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION AND WHEN.
AND PAGE WRITES ABOUT TALKING
POINTS FOR JAMES COMEY.
"POTUS WANTS TO KNOW EVERYTHING
WE ARE DOING."
MR. OBAMA DIDN'T ONCE -- DIDN'T
HE WANTS INSIST HE NEVER GOT
INVOLVED?
INVESTIGATIONS.
I CANNOT TALK TO FBI DIRECTORS
ABOUT PENDING INVESTIGATIONS.
WE HAVE A STRICT LINE AND I'VE
ALWAYS MAINTAINED IT.
>> TO BUTTONED THIS UP.
>> I GUARANTEE THERE IS NO
POLITICAL INFLUENCE IN ANY
INVESTIGATION CONDUCTED BY THE
FULL'S.
PERIOD.
>> Kimberly: FULL.
DANA.
>> Dana: IT COULD LOOK
TERRIBLE OR IT COULD BE HE HAS
THE ELECTION.
FROM THESE TEXT MESSAGES, WE
DON'T OF THAT.
YOU COULD ALSO BE BRIEFED AND
NOT TRY TO WEIGH IN IF YOU ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT RUSSIAN
INVOLVEMENT.
THE DNC WAS TRAIN WE WERE HACKE.
THE RUSSIANS DID THIS.
ONE OF THE CRITICISMS OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA FROM DEMOCRATS
AS HE DIDN'T DO ENOUGH TALKING
ABOUT RUSSIAN MEDDLING IN THE
ELECTION.
IF THIS WERE REALLY ABOUT THE
WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
IF IT'S ABOUT HILLARY'S EMAIL
SCANDAL AND IF PRESIDENT OBAMA
WANTED TO SQUASH IT, HE WASN'T
VERY EFFECTIVE.
TEN DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION IS
WHEN JAMES COMEY SENDS A LETTER
TO CONGRESS THAT SAYS I AM
HILLARY CLINTON, IN HER BOOK AND
INTERVIEWS, BLAMES JAMES COMEY
FOR HER LOSS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, ANY
CLARITY?
>> Jesse: I WISH I DID.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW MORE.
THEY SHOULD BE TESTIFYING.
INVOLVED IN THE FBI SHENANIGANS.
IF HE WANTS TO KNOW IF THE FBI
IS UP TO.
IS IT ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION?
THAT WAS CLOSED WHEN THIS TEXT
WAS SENT.
>> Dana: THE ANTHONY WEINER
INVESTIGATION.
>> Jesse: WASN'T ABOUT THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA INVESTIGATION?
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
IF IT WAS ABOUT THE DNC HACK,
THEY NEVER GOT THE DNC SERVER
FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
THAT IS SUSPICIOUS.
OBAMA SAYS HE DOESN'T COMMENT ON
PENDING INVESTIGATIONS READY
COMMENTED ON THE OTHER
INVESTIGATION ON CAMERA.
HE SAID IT NEVER JEOPARDIZED
NATIONAL SECURITY.
COMEY CONTRADICTED HIM AND SAID
IT DID.
IT WAS MORE THAN THAT.
LOIS LERNER TOOK THE FIFTH.
YOU HAD TEXT MESSAGES THING WE
WHAT IS THE TASK AT HAND?
IF THEY ARE SO TERRIFIED ABOUT
THE ELECTION OF PRESIDENT TRUMP,
TWO THAT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO BY
THE INSURANCE POLICY THEY
HATCHED IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S OFFICE.
THAT'S RIGHT THEY SHOULD
TESTIFY.
THEY'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT A
PHONE THEY HAVE WHERE THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON'S
INVESTIGATION AND WE CAN'T TALK
ON THIS PHONE.
WHERE DID THAT PHONE GO?
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT PHONE.
MAYBE THEY SMASHED IT WITH A
HAMMER, LIKE HILLARY.
THEY ARE TRUMP HATERS AND THEY
ARE SNOBS BECAUSE THEY REFERRED
AND THEY LOVE HIM TO DEATH.
THEY HATE CONGRESSIONAL
OVERSIGHT.
THEY WERE BESMIRCHING THE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS.
THERE'S ALSO A WIDE GAP, VERY
INTERESTING COME ON THE 28TH OF
SEPTEMBER, 2016, THEY DISCOVERED
THE HUMA ABEDIN-HILLARY EMAILS
ON WEINER'S LAPTOP.
BRIEFED ON THE NEW EMAILS THEY
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT.
PEOPLE DISCOVER SUSPECT McCABE
MAY HAVE HAD SOMETHING TO DO
OR LATER.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS IT'S CLEAR
NOW THAT THE TRUMP-HATING FBI
AGENTS WERE ON AN ANTI-TRUMP
MISSION AND PRESIDENT OBAMA MAY
BE INVOLVED.
THE JOKE IS ON YOU, JUAN.
>> Juan: THEY TALK ABOUT FOG
IT'S OBVIOUS THE PRESIDENT, AND
DANA PICKED UP ON THIS,
IN TERMS OF THE RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, THAT HE AND THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES HAD
CONFIRMED WAS TAKING PLACE
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE IDEA THAT THE FBI SHOULD BE
BRIEFING THE PRESIDENT ON
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IS NOT
FAR-FETCHED.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
WANTED TO BE BRIEFED ON?
>> Juan: THE CIRCUMSTANCES,
THE TIMING IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
NOT ONLY THAT,
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" HAS AN
ARTICLE ON TODAY AND IT SAYS
TEXT FROM THE 2016 PREPARATIONS
TO BRIEF BARACK OBAMA ABOUT
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IN THAT
YEAR'S ELECTION.
SHOW.
YOU THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD,
INSTEAD OF ALWAYS THROWING UP
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, DETRACTED
FROM THE INDEFENSIBLE,
DONALD TRUMP, YOU MIGHT COME
WITH FACTS?
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE BEEN
CALLING THIS CONSPIRACY FOR THE
LAST YEAR.
EVERY TIME FACTS, COME IT PROVES
YOU WRONG.
>> Juan: GIVE ME SOME FACTS.
>> Juan: PLEASE.
DON'T BRING OBAMA INTO IT.
>> Jesse: I DIDN'T BRING HIM
INTO AGE.
PART OF THE ELEMENT FOR
WHO WANTS TO MAKE IT -- EVEN --
EVEN TODAY ERIC HOLDER AT A
BREAKFAST MEETING SAID
PRESIDENT OBAMA NEVER CONTACTED
HIM ABOUT ANY FBI
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Jesse: I DON'T TRUST ERIC
HOLDER AS FAR AS I CAN THROW HIM
HOLDER AS FAR AS I CAN THROW HI
HIM.
>> Tom: DIDN'T WE SAY, PLAY A
CLIP OF PRESIDENT OBAMA NOT
GETTING INVOLVED.
WHETHER IT'S ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
OR THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION, HE
IS INVOLVED.
GOING ON WITH THE RUSSIANS
TRYING TO INFLUENCE AN AMERICAN
ELECTION.
>> Juan:
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" IS
TOO.
>> Tom: WITH EVERY BOMBSHELL,
WE ARE GETTING SHELL-SHOCKED.
NO ONE IS A BOMBSHELL.
EVERY TIME YOU INFORMATION, NEW
TEXTS CAME OUT, WE FORGET ABOUT
THE LAST ONE.
THE BEST REFERENCES IN THESE
STRZOK-PAGE TEXT, HAVE TO DO
WITH HILLARY.
ANDY'S OFFICE MEETING.
NEW EMAILS CAME OUT, THE HUMA
AND WEINER EMAILS.
STRZOK SAYS "WILL THIS NEVER
END?"
HE IS DYING TO WRAP UP THIS
HILLARY THING.
YOU GO BACK FIVE MONTHS BEFORE
WHEN TRUMP WAS GOING TO BE THE
NOMINEE, REMEMBER WHEN CRUZ
DROPPED OUT, THEY WERE GOING
CRAZY ON THE TEXT.
OH, MY GOSH.
I NOW THE PRESSURE STARTS.
HE WAS TRYING TO WRAP UP THE
HILLARY INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS YOUR EVIDENCE, JUAN.
BRING IN THE JURY.
I AM READY TO LECTURE TO THE
JURY.
SO MANY INCRIMINATING TEXTS.
>> Dana: IT WILL NEVER END.
WE ARE STILL TALKING ABOUT IT.
ONE THING IT DOES GO BACK TO
IT, INCLUDING THE WHITE HOUSE,
THAT ALLOWED HER TO HAVE A
DESTROYED, WIPED FROM THE
SERVER.
TALKING ABOUT INVESTIGATIONS ON
THEIR GOVERNMENT PHONES.
BLOWS ME AWAY.
A LOT OF IT WAS REDACTED.
>> Kimberly: WE DIDN'T GET THE
GOOD STUFF.
>> Dana: AT ONE POINT HE SAYS
IS IT OKAY FOR ME TO SEND YOU
SOME PICTURES.
>> Kimberly: COMING UP ON
"THE FIVE."
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: WE DON'T HAVE
PICTURES.
>> Juan: WE LIKE PICTURES.
>> Dana: NO, WE DON'T PRETTY I
AM PRETTY SURE WE DON'T.
>> Juan: UNBELIEVABLE HOW MANY
EMAILS THEY SENT.
DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN'T HAVE
IT'S JUST PEOPLE WITH A BIAS.
THEY CAN'T PUT IT ASIDE.
HE'S GOING TO BE PRESIDENT.
I'M LOSING MY MIND!
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S VERY INCRIMINATING.
>> Juan: ELECTION DAY 2016,
THERE WERE PEOPLE IN THIS
BUILDING.
>> Dana: THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN -- IF THEY WERE TRYING TO
STOP SOMETHING, THEY WERE VERY
INEFFECTIVE BECAUSE, AGAIN,
COMEY'S LETTER TEN DAYS BEFORE
THE ELECTION IS WHAT SO MANY
WOMEN SUPPORT DROP IN ALL OF THE
KEY STATES.
>> Tom: OUR GUY, STRZOK,
CHANGED THE WORDS.
EXTREMELY NEGLIGENT TO.
JULY, NOT SEPTEMBER.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR YOUR
DEFENSE, JUAN.
HILLARY'S CRONY SID BLUMENTHAL,
AND TY TRUMP SMEARS THROUGH THE
DOSSIER.
BASED ON RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
SOURCES AND SID BLUMENTHAL'S
LIES.
THE FBI ALSO KNEW CHRISTOPHER
STEELE HAD BEEN LYING AND HAVE
BEEN LEAKING TO THE PRESS YET
THEY STILL USED THE.CA AND THEY
THAT AS JUSTIFICATION FOR SPYING
ON THE TRUMP ASSOCIATES.
WHY WOULD THE FBI DO THAT?
>> Kimberly: WE HAVE TREY
GOWDY ON THIS AND I WILL ASK FOR
YOUR REACTION, JUAN.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR WHO ONE OF THE
SOURCES OF THE INFORMATION IS,
YOU'RE GOING TO THINK OH, MY
GOSH.
I HAVE HEARD THAT NAME SOMEWHERE
BEFORE.
WHERE COULD HAVE POSSIBLY BEEN?
>> THE FOREIGN SOURCE?
>> THE DOMESTIC SOURCE.
WHO EMAILED HER FROM TIME TO
TIME.
>> SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL.
>> THAT WOULD BE WARM, REALLY
WARM.
>> Juan: I DON'T GET IT.
>> Jesse: WE KNOW, JUAN.
YOU DON'T GET IT.
>> Juan: I DON'T GET WHAT YOU
THINK THIS IS SOMEHOW AN
INDICTMENT OF THE STEELE DOSSIER
OR THE INVESTIGATION.
I WOULD HOPE YOU WOULD HAVE
EVERY RESOURCE AVAILABLE IF YOU
ARE TRYING TO GET INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THE RUSSIANS ARE
TRYING TO INFLUENCE OUR ELECTION
AND POTENTIALLY COLLUDING.
>> Jesse: THE SOURCE OF THE
DOSSIER WAS A HILLARY CRONY AND
RUSSIAN LINERS IN THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S ENOUGH TO
PRESENT TO A JUDGE TO SPY ON
AMERICANS?
IT'S NOT.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
YOU CANNOT PRESENT UNVERIFIED
INFORMATION TO A FISA JUDGE.
>> Jesse: JESSE, SLOW DOWN.
LET ME TALK FOR A SECOND.
YOU MIGHT LEARN SOMETHING.
THE JUDGE WAS TOLD THE SOURCE OF
THE DOSSIER WAS A POLITICAL
PARTISAN.
THE JUDGE UNDERSTOOD THIS.
POLITICAL.
>> Jesse: NO BEARING WHETHER
OR NOT THE OPPONENT YOU ARE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AGAINST.
IT WASN'T TRUE.
WHAT WAS TRUE ABOUT THE DOSSIER?
>> Juan: I AM NOT GETTING INTO
THAT HERE BUT -- ALL WE KNOW
ABOUT IS TODAY THIS BUSINESS
ABOUT THE FBI LOVERS AND THEIR
TEXTS, YOU GUYS ARE SO DESPERATE
TO SOMEHOW UNDERMINE ROBERT
MUELLER.
YOU WILL DO ANYTHING.
REPUBLICANS WILL PUT ON BLINDERS
REPUBLICANS WILL PUT ON BLINDER
BLINDERS.
>> Kimberly: YOU ARE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO PROFFER ONE FACT FORWARD
THAT WAS ACCURATE OR TRUE IN THE
DOSSIER TO SUPPORT THAT.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT THE
>> Dana: THAT IS ONE THING
TREY GOWDY SAID TO MARTHA LAST
NIGHT.
REGARDLESS OF THE DOSSIER, THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN AN INVESTIGATION
ABOUT RUSSIAN MEDDLING THE
ELECTION.
THE OTHER THING ABOUT THE
GRASSLEY MEMO THAT IRRITATES ME
ABOUT THE NUNES MEMO.
THIS WHOLE THING ABOUT HOW YOU
SHOULDN'T TAKE A YAHOO NEWS
ARTICLE AND TO CONVINCE THE
JUDGE THERE IS CORROBORATION.
IN THE GRASSLEY MEMO, IT SAYS IT
WASN'T USED FOR CORROBORATION.
THE YAHOO! NEWS ARTICLE.
I GET CAUTIOUS ABOUT COMMENTING
ON ALL OF THIS BECAUSE IT IS
CHERRY PICKED INFORMATION.
>> Jesse: I DON'T GET WHAT YOU
SAYS THE YAHOO! NEWS ARTICLE WAS
USED TO COOPERATE.
THAT'S NOT WHY THE ARTICLES
REFERENCED.
THE GRASSLEY MEMO APPEARS TO
CONFIRM IT WAS NOT PRESENT FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CORROBORATION.
>> Kimberly: THERE IS A
CONTRADICTION.
>> Jesse: I DIDN'T SEE THAT.
I KNOW THEY DIDN'T PRESENTED
ALONGSIDE THE DOSSIER.
>> Tom: I WILL BE CALM, JUAN,
I WILL BE FRIENDLY.
IT'S DIRTY.
>> Juan: I THINK PETER STRZOK
IS GOING TO START SENDING TEXTS